hopefully when you get married or you  fall in love with someone they're as  important as you or  perhaps even more so but when you have  children it's definitively the case that  now someone is more important than you  and that's such a relief and it is a  crucial part of maturation to have that  happen i don't think  it's possible to grow up without having  children oh  it's unlikely he's still got it he can  still drop a bond more  that's going to stir people up yeah well  i it's hard to grow up until someone's  more important than you so  why would you why wouldn't you continue  being siboratic and  living at least to some degree for  pleasure